[Music]
chris what's a player that you leads
like to play against and why
there's there's really no player um that
i hate playing against i mean i love you
know all the challenges that come across
the different type of players in the
league the good ones the bad ones in
between it's all a challenge on yourself
to you know play at your best so really
don't dislike playing against anybody
bobby how do you relax and reset off the
court
i relax and
kind of reset off the court by just
having good family and friends around um
i go bowling here and here and there
that's like my favorite hobby to do and
um just relaxing at the career watching
movies and things
what tv series are you watching right
now
it's the the bml series
about 50 cent that's like my favorite
one i can't wait for season two to come
out for like the season one ending too
fast and i'm watching squid game too so
yeah
i'm a little late
i'm getting to it
what's your favorite post game meal
it depends on the day for real but i'm
gonna bake some salmon got a little
salmon and then i could throw some um
you know potatoes and asparagus in with
it
yeah a little healthy
who's the best teammate in training
be careful
who the guy sitting next to you or not
what's the most important thing you
learned from me
uh on the court probably just i always
been in there and helped side
positioning and things like that you
always yelling and stuff
off the court just sacrificing you know
uh before i got here
my sacrifice
with basketball but
being around y'all guys i had to sac i
learned how to sacrifice more things in
life and things like that so
y'all definitely helped me out on that
aspect but i think one of the most
important things i learned from bobby is
just the intensity brings that every
night the heart that you have to play
with the grit um just you know no days
off no minutes off no possessions
everything is all out every possession
who's the best advocate for performance
nutrition on the team that's tough
that's tough
we all got we all got our bad habits
yes
it might be it might be drew
drew might be the best one
pat also yeah y'all will go with drew
and pat those are the two penis
healthiest guys pat don't even drink
you got uh any superstitions
so like i got to put my left shoe on
before my right shoe now i'm saying what
and i got to top my right shoe before my
left shoe i'm just left i gotta pick the
left sock on left shoe first time really
don't matter but i gotta talk about my
first time if i don't mind like the
right way i'll be feeling like crazy
all right what's your favorite sis
product
minus the hydro i love the hydro that
suzie prepares
before the game during practice after
practice and things like that should do
a good job of that
what track needs to be on the on the
locker room playlist
i should ask you man you you're the
music guy the dj mostly got all the new
songs i'm always the old ones uh
so i'll let you answer this one i can't
think of a song right now
let's go
the easiest artist is drake and jay-z
for me
i like a little baby
there you go
there you go
who has the biggest character on the
team
the biggest character got a lot of
low-key guys
i would say
i might throw you in there with uh
sandro
um
i got bro brooke yeah that's probably
brooks rehearsal i've been missing yeah
so probably broke for sure
who's got the worst fashion sense
man we can't do that
i already know you're going to say it
too he's going to get in trouble
please